this is the technical difficulties for
playing citation needed join me today he
reads books you know it's Chris Joel
Gary's line just before Gary said it so
Gary's isn't funny remember that
everybody's favorite Gary Brannen Gary
Brennan and now on itv1 our new Saturday
night's entertainment game show join
Stephen Mulhern and get out
that's my trout and I'll be following up
on itv2 with your reaction in front of
me I've got a novel from Wikipedia and
these folks can't see it every fight we
get right is a point and a ding and the
special prize for particular dancers
which is
today we are talking about the Crazy
Eights incident Crazy Eights are the
crazy Apes because whatever sounds
brilliant the Crazy Eights instant also
known as the CSX
eight eight eight eight is it Chinese
they like eights then they oh bloody
hell
you saw no you're completely utterly
wrong yes that would be lucky number
this is a not in China and be very only
said to there this is this is a not in
China and be not lucky
was it a lucky CSX Transportation does
that open e in question flight no public
transport oh that's more freight carrier
is it a runaway train to do the whole
first line is it that film Oh which
affair was a film with the guy that
played Kirk in the new Star Trek's a
little bit Chris Pine yes I think and it
was all under cranked out officially
sped up footage of American trains
moving really slowly I saw about ten
minutes of that it was terrible terrible
it was amazing it's got terrible pun
name as it's something like just run
away Denzel Washington and Chris Pine
yes you've skipped a huge amount to the
odds here because that is the film based
on this incident
so go run it will go train what is
running away yes not cause it scared
cause it naughty now if I remember from
the film it was running away towards a
city that had a very tight bend in it
and there was something that it couldn't
fall off and destroy and it had terrible
things inside it now why did you a movie
pitch career never take off have you not
heard me describing things before but
never so compelling you're right with
some of that it did have bad things in
it is it radiation II I don't know
no is it chemically yes I'm gonna give a
point for that I feel like I shouldn't
chemically bad things yeah thousands of
gallons of phenol is that a solvent of
phenolic acid is it an acid
we're not just get a runaway train of
gaviscon taste it yeah you also right uh
that the movie had devil's curve in the
city of Stanton is there actually a city
of Stanton I don't the city of Stanton
the suddenly isn't a devil's curve is it
is it just a bad curve no the train with
the actual real train which was CSX
eight eight eight eight that was a
registry number uh was not headed
towards anything particularly dangerous
Hollywood found a vaguely boring but
someone thought all if we if we made
this worse than it actually was it'll be
compelling gonna film yes I like the
thought of someone sat at home with
their kids trained search I think how
can I make this film exciting and they
just kick did a little bit of track and
it bends and he goes fair we this is
notable for one particular aspect of the
fact that there were no significant
injuries or anything from it it's
notable for one thing that a film made
about it
two things tried to do the sort of
stupid that you see in the film why they
pull a train alongside and somebody laps
across to try and slow it down yes so
someone haven't seen a film tried to do
something they might see in a film well
it was a little more thought-out than
that but yes this this was rescued dummy
with such faint praise so first of all
what went wrong
what's be what's happening here catch up
to it and pull up next to it to do the
the jumpy thing
how would you pull up next to it yes
I'll get this oh no no they knew what it
was on and it's also notable for how far
it went why is it running away that's
how the show works Gary Gary why was it
running awhile
alright if I sit on or off ever so
slightly they should have vacuumed
break-ins it's the breaking the vacuum
pipe the break should come on
so as the driver collapsed or something
oh you are so close until the end yeah
I'm still give your point because this
starts in a classification yard or a
marshalling yard that's known in the UK
so that's where they move stuff about
and put them on the and the freight gets
moved and yes stranger things are made
up into train yeah no mommy decorating
and the Daddy train
there are different types of yard what's
a hump yard shouldn't without connecting
it's over a hump it's it's a hill and it
runs down via gravity and you can you
can break it at the top by popping
things between the rails to catch the
wheels to slow them slightly swimming in
a big room cause a big leaver and goes
like that and they stop those well I
can't do it again he's already passed
doesn't it it's a different lever before
anyone says anything else there's also a
gravity yard I want to see the
antigravity yard some bats are moving in
between tracks because you can just
shove them side where he's gentle it's
the same thing it's just a hill it run
down them yeah it's literally right the
trains are here and you push them down
the hill you just start them going and
then you just have to align all the
points up and the switches oh so it went
wrong
yes alignment to the output instead of
to a siding and then they just kept
going so it's it's not actually gravity
yard here it's a flat yard but the
engineer on the train noticed that one
of the switches points is misaligned so
what does he do it deep with a big
hammer where he can't break fast enough
he knows the trains not gonna see a jump
off yes he did ah now what you've done
there mate now what you've done that
you've left you train off its own and no
point is this Thomas and the train will
stop for not having a driver yes he did
he did actually apply the air brake but
the air brake was disconnected
because it's in the middle of a yard and
they don't yes yeah yeah and he might
only have the engine brake which won't
stop a full train yes but it did turn
off the Deadman switch now because the
brakes pushed now that is very silly if
you take the keys out you can't actually
stop it can you know do you know do they
well here know what a dynamic brake on a
trainers oh god I know that's well the
apt head isn't it
that's such fluid dynamic brake brake
wasn't it a dynamic brake is using the
throttle to power the brakes
that's it recharges the breakers by the
reserve energy because there are
electric motors rather than just a
diesel engine driving the wheels it's a
diesel engine driving an electric motor
and user to recharge brake circuits yes
like using a flywheel as a brake a
little bit you're having kinetic energy
into the other sorry I'm going just a
bit engineering I thought having these
discussions while the train was running
away out of the yard what happens if for
example you fail to set the dynamic
brake and then send power to it
ah now does that just make the brakes
not work even better no it's just gonna
accelerate oh she just oh you just made
it go faster there mate yes
Lenny jumped off he hurt yes now now
what he really did there this is America
right mm-hmm I think I know about
America is that it's big yeah yes quite
so and America has big long straight
bits of railway with nothing yes was
this a diesel engine and did they just
wait for the diesel to run out they've
got quite a bear diesel on there haven't
they yes did they just wait they've got
quite a bit of America - no they didn't
but you're along some the right lines
where I said this was notable why it was
notable I mean it was notable for
something in particular about this do
they try and slow from the diesel out
while it was driving is this the train
that's traveled on its own the longest
no I don't think know if it's officially
the longest but it is certainly a very
very long distance it went for two hours
at somewhere around fifty miles an hour
that's nearly a hundred miles yes there
are all sorts of movie plot threats and
ideas that you've come up with here what
are they actually gonna try and do to it
what's the practical solution to runaway
train get one of those little carts well
has the pompey thing on and go dead
faster you catch up with it down a hill
and then you climb a ball along the top
and get in the driver's cabin and and
and turn it off do that but with another
locomotive yes break it right they also
plan to do that they didn't actually
need to do that in time did it crash by
that fight no no there are what's what's
the plan here so first of all they use
something called a portable D
so they want to jump for the wheels off
the track so then it's grinding more
than driving and then it'll just slow
down because it hasn't got enough grip
yeah well more than that it will not the
wheels off the track and just I think
that's not a great place for a
locomotive to be in at this point you
get the police coming out throwing a
stinger trap underneath it trying to pop
the the police did try to do something
shoot it
yes try to hit something on it the fuel
line's the brake oh not quite the driver
said that political jokes after the fire
the flash diesel say won't ignite but
yes but you could shoot the fuel eyes on
tanks the fuel tank at the emergency
fuel cutoff switch is closed it's a
switch yes so we now have runaway train
that has been shot at by the police
successfully shut up with the
accelerator being a bit stuck down yeah
and the the other brake being on but
essentially being completely burned out
by this what's the plan what do they go
with we have experienced railroad
engineers here put it in reverse somehow
while the power of the mind you sorta
suggested this earlier what drive
another vehicle couplet and then use
those brakes yes so the two engineers in
a train coming the other way
pulled are coming that train to pass hmm
and then chased it that must have looked
awesome
yes when was this - the video it there
is video of the runaway train but not of
this actual mumsy's of massive other
sites Oh 2001 yeah massive oversee get a
helicopter over this you got rights so
an engineer with 31 years of service
nice is in last day before retirement
and a rookie conductor with one years
experience
but listen to me kid I am looks down
imagine camera the engineer hooks a
picture of dead wife I watched that film
thinking it was so funny lake but it
actually happened like that
yes then the train master is the Train
mr. Brunel
you have been a very naughty engine they
listen and Ringo has in the back of the
trends in the real issue did the young
engineer try and go first and the old
engineer said no you've got too much to
live for the train master John Huss
field ran alongside the train 11 miles
long and shuts down the engine yes
they have another train up front ready
to try and RAM it not quite Ram it but
you've slowed it down by brave man Ram
it yes what happened to the engineer who
first made the mistake wait so it's now
stop every covered it's going back to
the yard the engineer at the start what
happened - he's made to lie down on the
rails it's actually a bit hard to work
out because they never released the name
of the engineer yeah and I think I would
either because in aviation you you don't
do that you don't go for blame you go
firts let's work out what happened and
then work out how mate to make it not
happen again yes that rather than it's a
blameless culture whatever they call
this so then things get reported you
values always systems or technology
that's eventually caused them and if not
if you think you're gonna get blamed for
something you're not going to report
that something happen and then you don't
get a good safety yeah it's called a
just culture those are literally
answered several the questions I was
about last time two points
so what's happen to the engine in the
end is it being destroyed as a warning
to others is it in a retirement home
well they're called Museum those are two
very different links for objects is a
museum okay okay he's not wrong but
that's that doesn't work the other way
around like a retirement home is not a
museum of people several railway museums
trying to buy it but officials replied
they did not feel it worthy of
preservation because you get this the
train will tell the other trains has to
run away knowledge and it was torn down
and rebuilt as part of a regular rebuild
process so it is not-- it is now bits of
it are now in other place it got hung
drawn and quartered yeah basically yeah
that's pretty much what I've got the
idea now of all these bits from other
trains and these bits are sent in and
suddenly at some point and here's the
second film lots of trains run away I'm
gonna sense this second one's written by
Stephen King ideally me but yeah so at
the end of the show congratulations Gary
you win this one
you win the rights to your screenplay
being produced no sorry um are you and a
shirt that exposes your midriff
sponsored by a series of Korean boy
bands
it's a k-pop crop top
[Music]
you